Laura your question for Rachel Cruz
hi Rachel hi Dave how are you better
than we deserve what's up I am 26 years
old I am a new listener to the show I
have had a full-time job since I
graduated college at 22 and also since I
graduated I decided to live at home with
my parents to save for because I have a
head
college debt and recently I had all this
money saved because I've looked at home
for a couple years now and I went to the
smart money tour and Akron Ohio oh yes
and yeah and so I've kind of been
putting it off putting it off paying my
debt and then after going to that talk I
realized what am i doing I should just
pay off all my debt right now so I
decided to pay off all my student loans
after that show because I had the money
just sitting in my account way to go
anything congratulations
how about being here oh my gosh like the
biggest weight lifted off my shoulders
it's so nice very cool much Tomasulo
debt did you have so I had what I was
paying monthly payments and since I
graduated college and I ended up paying
$20,000 after the talk on November 1st
so $49 yep that's free as far student
loans go and I actually since I've been
living at home I have I do have extra
money that I've been saving as well and
I just wanted to know I wanted a little
bit of direction on where I should be
putting that money that I saved because
I still have a full-time job so wait how
much month what do you make I make forty
four thousand for you and you have any
other debt other than those student
loans you paid off I do not because I
decided to pay my car I bought a used
car and I did I decided to pay that and
fall good good for you and how much
money do you have saved in the account
today today I have about $30,000 bill
totally yes are you girl you are getting
it I love it congratulations
well what I would say for you your first
step are you still living at home I am
still living at home okay so if I were
you at 26 now that you don't have debts
I would move out I think I'm finding
your own place even if it's if you're
renting somewhere which is probably what
I would suggest first and foremost find
an apartment find a house go and step
out and move out on your own because
it's amazing what will unleash in you
just as a person when you're not under
mom and dad's roof and so the idea of
being out and being independent things
are just going to change in your life
and you you're going to grow up so much
faster than what you even think I know
you're grown up obviously you've done
amazing job with your money so far
but it really springboards you into your
own life so first and foremost I would
take that step go and and and rent
somewhere but with the remaining money
you have then I would definitely say
looking just to a traditional money
market account just at your bank or an
online Becky even if there's a better
rate of return but that's going to be
for your emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and so I'm figuring
out what three to six months of expenses
is for you and put that amount of money
away and put that just in a money market
account something you can get to quickly
and then above that beyond that or I
would I would really look at to you know
investing a little bit more chris hogan
talked about that at the event but
looking into like a roth IRA or if your
company has a 401k something to start
putting money towards retirement cuz
you're there i mean you're at that step
i'm pretty i mean i'm confident you
already have your emergency fund in
place for that money market account but
i would look into things like retirement
investing and then it's are stuff that
you want to do you know next year i know
you said you just bought a car so you
may not need to upgrade soon but if
there's a vacation you want to take them
if their stuff you want to do i mean you
you have the cash available to be able
to start really thinking and being able
to do some amazing things so being
intentional with the money that's above
that emergency fund and what you could
do not only to enjoy your life of being
smart about it as well so do you have a
copy of rachel's book I do not know kind
of cool well we're going to give you a
copy we're very proud of you love your
life not theirs is her is on the way
Rachel sign it to you and Kelly will
ship it out to you hold on she'll pick
up and get all of your information so we
can send that right the fresh air though
Wow
that's right a still saved
for debt and 26 years old and went to
smart money and went back home and did
the stuff it's amazing yeah very well
done what are you s Millennials we're
not all failures hey we don't have
people out there though they they rag on
the Millennial culture there's some of
them but man that's they have Ramsey
solutions it's it's out there on the out
there on the Internet you can read it
it's out there floating around social
media we're fans of Millennials yes we
like them we think there's only two
kinds awesome and sucks and and they
pretty well tell you which one they are
when they walk in the door when so
encouraging those which is also when you
talk to people like that though but I'm
like you know there's 46 year olds they
don't have I don't have that you know
didn't have any six-year-olds I don't
have that clear so way to go or that's
so awesome
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show